I wasn't going to do this here would you
marry me Jane the Virgin shocked fans
with a surprise proposal on this week's
episode of the hit CW dramedy and only
ET was on set with the stars during the
big moment the proposal I think is
perfect yeah yeah I've never shot it yet
so I hope it ends up being perfect but I
am my head and what's written is pretty
awesome how are you feeling right now
I'm like nervous about I'm I'm really
excited I it's funny because um
emotionally I mean I cried during the
table read so I'm super excited when I
read it I got super actually excited and
like happy for him and I I also got
teary eyed yeah because he's worked so
long for this you know well I don't
think Michael was preparing for this but
he heard Jane say something very
specific that kind of made him go okay
I'm doing this this is it so it was kind
of like just gut and just going with
your heart type thing
you are absolutely who I want and I'm
not going anywhere and why do you feel
like Michael is the best fit for Jane
because he understands her he knows like
the inner workings of Jane and he
doesn't let go of it and he's fought to
protect her all these years and I just
love that and I think that's the kind of
husband Jane is always dreamed of your
poor future who ever yeah but for future
whoever is screwed is right that's so
true oh I've never posted like four
times on this show so that'd be really
good